[Music]
my new goal would be to get ranked 1 in
every single server actually only had
six months to prove myself and if I
didn't I would have to go to university
as I promised lesson
I know template you can't get challenger
template you can get d1
holy-moly template you won't get out of
this template you're working out of debt
[Music]
blah blah blah
here's your proof that's dumb boys the
u.s. is officially done holy Toledo
oh my gosh bro I'm done this region you
go for right one in this region but
really you want me to not be talks like
the magician running it down in my games
I smack night people move me Hoss I
think Turkish writers are working at
this are you ready for Korea ah yeah
almost every single losing game you call
your jungle or bad or read bad and it's
not acceptable increased and dark in a
day is fine I will go for a second run
at fright games excuse me a second
account
hopefully they give me another account
so as you guys might have noticed
spotlight looks a little bit different
and that's because much like the rest of
the world we're doing our part to stop
the spread of cope in nineteen which
means bringing you that same great
content just now from the comfort of our
own homes so you know stay safe and wash
your hands
okay back to the story TF blade is one
of league's biggest twitch streamers he
averages around 10k viewers and
dominates the competition with champions
like Orillia and Jax
[Music]
but before he was the king of solo cutie
a blade was just a normal high school
kid trying to convince his parents to
let him pursue career in eSports
I remember the conversations with my
parents that at least you know give him
a year and if he can prove himself to be
who he wants to be then then you should
give him that chance right now but after
his pro plans fell through
he spent his remaining time trying to
make streaming work instead you know I
was actually nervous doesn't beginning I
mean it's a whole new thing I only had
six months to prove myself and if I
didn't I would have to go to university
as I promised and due to those
self-imposed challenges that got a
stream rolling TF blades thirst for rank
one was born
that's dumb boys the mission is complete
it started with na and then he set his
sights on Latin America whether you
write - I think I got rank - whoo we got
him all right one more baby and it's
over
just one more egg and we're done with
this server as he conquered his second
region TF blades ambitions grew bigger
he wanted to be first all over the world
but that kind of challenge is expensive
yeah he could play North American and
Latin American north servers from his
home but other regions required travel
but luckily for TF blade he was about to
get some help that would turn his dream
into a reality we were going to be
joining the team liquid streaming team
ever since I've played this game I
always had this dream of becoming the
best player at it and so recently I
finally got to become the rank 1 player
in the North American servers however
this is not enough for me I'm planning
to get ranked 1 in every single server
actually thanks to Team Liquid TF blades
global rank 1 challenge was ago they're
offering me free boot camps to different
countries to resolve my ping issues and
his first stop on this global tour was
EU West I screenshot - it's literally
done juji all right well it's
was a good ride boys the u.s. people
lesson I know
template you can't get challenger
template you can get d1 template you
won't get out of this template you're
winging it out of doubt blah blah blah
here's your proof midway through 2019 he
had three regions under his belt and he
planned on Turkey to be his fourth look
at the solution look into the Challenger
just look at the solution challenge
but the Turkish region wasn't exactly
welcoming 2tf blade in fact they
straight-up trolled him doing everything
they could to stop him from reaching
Rank 1 on their server but a [ __ ] is my
mid laner they even held him hostage in
his 60 plus minute game with the enemy
team refusing to end that game while his
team just sat in base tilted off the
face of the planet TF blade lashed out
in chat the result I have 14 day ban 14
days no IDs not only two games not even
3 games also are you [ __ ] you wanted
to not because I couldn't interested
running it down in my games what are you
doing about it I imported them I sent
thickets to you
you didn't abandon you didn't you [ __ ]
but he shook off that tilt and once he
got unbanned he jumped right back on
that grind for EU nordic and east
holy never did though oh my gosh bro
I've been playing so much now hey it's
done yo buddy hey hey
how you doing hi look at the gym I've
even growing facial hair before I see
those college players come 2020 though
TF blade vowed to finish his global
quest and his first stop of the new year
was going to be his hardest challenge
yet Korea where do I put it
hey it doesn't work
why does it no why
god damn my campaign cities don't
hopefully I can't find them bro the
Korean server is considered the final
boss of solo queue it's the preferred
training destination for pros looking to
improve not only do top Chinese and
Korean pros practice there but the level
of play is considered a lot higher than
any other region and despite the
language barrier TF blade made it work
oh good the light bulb guy having saved
Chuck will unfortunately for him though
he just couldn't keep his mouth shut in
game and said some stuff that might be
allowed in the West but is definitely a
no-go in Korea so he got banned again
almost every single losing game beep all
your jungle or bad or meet bad what are
you guys doing why are you so bad you
did that so many times and it's not
acceptable increase standard in a day is
fine it's normal now that he's home
after losing his Korean account TF
blades already back on an unranked to
rank one challenge in North America for
him this band was more of a bump in the
road than a failure
he couldn't get Rank 1 this time but
he's faced adversity in this challenge
before always coming back stronger than
ever
well yeah I think for Korea wise though
since you guys are asking a lot I do
want to go back go for a second run it
like even this run that I had it was
amazing I will go for a second round if
Riot Games just gives me a second
account
hopefully they give me another account I
do want to just not [ __ ] type or ping
people but I will see let's just hope
that next time he meets the chat thanks
for watching if you want more content
like this hit the sub button and ring
that notification bell for unique
bite-sized videos you will find anywhere
else hit up art Instagram Twitter and
Facebook pages